The joe rogan experience.
Why wouldn't we assume that the reason
why we're so conflicted and weird is
because that's the proper mechanism that
needs to be in place for people to move
forward in the direction
that we're moving forward.
It'd be,
it'd be constantly chasing technology
without any real clear sort of a rational
approach to using our
resources and looking at the
problems that we have because
we're like a bunch of little kids that
have like shit all over their house,
but instead we're,
we're outside working on the garden,
you know,
we're planting trees,
we're not cleaning up the shit that we
piled up in the middle of the living room
and it keeps piling up every day to the
point where we can't even live in our
house anymore and we're concentrating
on some shit that's not even ours.
Do you think you could ever,
you probably couldn't,
but maybe in your,
maybe it stayed,
like if you didn't have kids,
in fact big family.
So do you think you could ever live in
like one of those airstream trailers by
myself?
Fuck yeah.
Cause I was recently,
I recently went to Joshua tree and
one of those and I was thinking like,
really this is all I really need and
I could take my whole fucking house
anywhere I want.
And the new ones have
like nice wood floors
and some of them expand out.
You know,
there's,
there's been,
um,
you know,
a lot of people that are moving
towards minimalist houses,
really small houses,
but there's a bunch of online that
show like how certain people live.
And it's kind of interesting,
you know,
like one guy figured out a way to have
like this little tiny cooking area and he
pulls the bed out in the bed,
comes out of the wall.
He lives by himself and he has
like some storage up in top,
like toilet paper and
things along those lines.
But it's a tiny,
tiny little house and a
little kitchen dinette area.
And you know,
the idea is that like,
really,
why do we have to have this giant fucking
footprint of House that we live in?
You know,
and
these guys are getting paid,
bitch,
if all I live in a fucking cell,
I'll live in a fucking
sound like a monkey.
I'm going to live on a fault
Puerto Rican that gets
a check on the fifth.
Go Fuck your mother.
If you get paid,
you live in a fucking house.
I'm going to live in a Mike Rowe
fucking house with a little kitchen.
The Cook,
like I got a black guy back
at me in the fucking ass.
I don't need that.
You spread out even me.
I'm no millionaire.
I've got a big fucking kitchen,
a micro house.
What do you fucking people talking about?
I just not thought of it though.
You can't take me into
those deep waters like Rico.
Fucking kill the brother right now.
A fucking house with a bed upside down.
Fuck that shit to say vantage of fuck you.
You get paid.
You fucking live like a normal
person going to Trump and say,
hey wig.
Move into a fucking thing to say but
it to see if you don't pick slap you.
If you don't have a Russian bitch
slapping in the fucking fire,
the fuck are these people,
micro houses in the fucking desert.
You play it out to the world
that like a doctor like a doctor.
You live your fucking life.
You're right.
Dooms Day.
I'm going to put a can of tomato soup
under my stairs to wait for the Marshall
to come.
When it's over,
it's over.
You got when they with your Dick out
and you take your fucking chances like a
man.
I'm gonna live like I fucking old.
$20 to a bookmaker downstairs in my house.
Get the fuck out of my face.
I want to live in one of the airstream.
Brian's down.
Joey's not.
I think we have a real clear line.
We feel like you're in one.
When you're in there,
it's,
it's pretty.
So somebody farts and you're in four
fucking speak for Lisa and you're like,
I paid $10,000 it's like
a smell your asshole.
Get the fuck Outta here.
Because everything's great.
In a small space.
They'll suddenly blows a fucking for
you will walk into a bathroom at the,
some of the Oh shit bothers you.
Even if they're your mother.
You look at them like
you dirty fucking Vicks,
light a candle,
slumped it live.
Nothing small.
Fuck that shit,
Bro.
Especially,
I'm never home though.
You know,
like I work so much.
I'm never hiding.
You're always fucking hall.
I'm home asleep.
Yeah.